bonsoir monsieur julien on sent dans ses
rayons alors on dit que 70% des
conteneurs qui rentre au canada
transitent par vancouver quel est
l'impact de cet arrêt des activités en
ce moment
écoutez
l'impact
l'impac et ce jusqu à grandir en thèse
qu'on connaît déjà à cosa pandémie de
batteur dans les livraisons
principalement soit peut-être les la
plus grande la plus grande un impact qui
vont avoir aussi un impact au niveau au
niveau des coûts vote soit parce que bon
des rapports occasionnels des bd sur
coup des déplacements de deux conteneurs
d'une nouvelle route donc tous ces
éléments à la hausse s'ajoute pas qu'est
ce que malheureusement qu'on connaît
déjà et donc aider des camionneurs
notamment qui doivent passer par les
états unis pour livrer leur marchandise
en ce moment bah écoute et
principalement avec les discussions que
j'ai eues avec certains professionnels
de la chaîne d'approvisionnement dont
bolloré logistique présentement il ya
aucune activité dans libre dans le port
de vancouver dont vous l'avez mentionné
tantôt en a au delà de 75 navires qui
ont mouillé l'anc injuste à tout
informaticien
porte conteneur on peut parler d'après
en moyenne de dix mille comptes erreur
par navire ivoire
containers qui sont présentement au
large des côtes de vancouver donc ça
c'est anormal ce pas comme ça d'habitude
là c'est vraiment lié à ce qui se passe
présentement
fait parce que bon en moyenne écoutez le
le port de l'emploi reçoivent un navire
par semaine donc présentement une 20
autres avions navires pardon qui n'avait
guibert les eaux de vancouver prévint
donc
comme je disais oh précédemment et
aucune activité donc ce qui bouge
présentement c'est qu'est ce qui est
acquis donc tant que quand les
containers qui vont être acquis vont
être délesté leur espérons que les
autorités vont en voir
s'en sortent les transports
fonctionnaient qu'est-ce que dans ces
conteneurs
et des caisses qui transigent parle
parle de vancouver on parle de biens de
consommation allant de vêtements
d'électronique
tout ce qu'on peut retrouver chez les
les les commerces que l'on connaît on a
aussi des éléments que de commodité des
grains on a
exemple des produits liquides on parle
de l'huile de canola on peut parler de
deux produits chimiques de pétrole aussi
des pièces automobiles des composants de
nos secteurs manufacturiers donc on
parle vraiment d'un amalgame de produits
qui a un impact s que ces bateaux
pourraient être redirigé vers le sens je
laisse aussi atone
écoutez à l'ennemi des informations qui
m'ont été partagé le parent de los
angele a présentement 80 navires lui qui
qui sont aux côtés du pardon je vois mal
comment on pourrait si vous me prêtez
l'expression des routes et cesser ces
navires lauber d'autre part est ce que
dans un optique au niveau de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
que les organisations plus
prévoir meilleure planification compte
tenu de ce qu'on vit présentement kiki
qui est sans précédent n'a pas deux
compères actif en tant que tel
donc est ce qu'il ya une possibilité de
passer par d'autres canaux même s'ils
n'étaient que le canal de suez canal de
panama acp et demi mais il faut être en
mesure de bien planifier ses achats et
tenir compte des coûts et aussi des
délais de grève est ce qu'une partie des
biens qu'on pourrait transporter par
avion nolisé
et pts et 1 comme quand je mentionnais
oui dans jargon de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement on va aller seul le
coût de l'option donc un comme il faut
il faut amener le conteneur à un endroit
où ce qu'on peut faire de la manutention
pour
pour les apprêter pour l'aider avion
sauf que écoutez je parle avec votre
chercher un petit peu plus tôt en mars
2020 on parlait de
doctrine conteneur
de 1800 à 3000 $ en mars 2021 on parle
de six à dix mille dollars qui est
récemment j'ai entendu des cris de
containers 23 24 25 mille dollars à bord
donc si on prend ces marchandises qui
sont sur lequel ont déjà payé 1 23 ou 24
mille dollars qu'ont les conditions pour
le transport aérien écrire on parle de
50 60 75 % plus cher en tant que tel ça
donne une idée en tout cas des coûts
astronomiques qui peuvent survenir à la
suite de tout cela on va surveiller cela
le canadien pacifique au moins reprendre
ses activités la semaine prochaine
réagit bien merci beaucoup ben en fait
vous supplions au baiser pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]